Good morning, Hank!
Wait, who the eff is Hank?
Hank is a sentient android from the Star Trek:
The Next Generation universe, who, as any
true fan would know, is capable of reproduction
because he had a daughter!
Aanyway, your video on Monday was one of my
favorite Vlogbrothers videos, ever, but I
can't believe you got your Star Trek facts
wrong!
Right, so it's Tuesday; I'm gonna upload this
tomorrow after spending all day flying across
the world with a baby, but right now it's
Tuesday; it's Question Tuesday, the day that
I answer real questions from real Nerdighters!
"Do you have a vegetable garden?"
Well, this is my backyard at the moment, so,
no, unless, are cigarettes vegetables? Because,
if so, yes!
"What's up with all the shoes and feet in
the foreign editions of your books?"
Are there a lot of shoes and feet in the foreign
editions of--? Holy crap, there are a lot
of shoes and feet in these foreign editions!
I don't know what's up with that!
"Did something happen with 'Let It Snow?'"
Yes, Hank, the movie rights to "Let It Snow"
just sold to Paramount, a large movie studio
out there in Hollywood. They also own the
movie rights to "Looking for Alaska," which
they have not yet made, but you never know,
maybe they'll make... one of them. Someday.
"Can Henry be in today's video?"
Briefly.
"During your stay, have you learned any Dutch?"
Koninginnedag!
"What are some of the major differences you've
noticed between the U.S. and Europe?"
Well, the biggest difference is that in the
US, sixty percent of bankruptcies are caused
by medical costs, whereas in the Netherlands,
zero percent of bankruptcies are caused by
medical costs.
"What's the title of your new book?"
It's still not totally decided, believe it
or not, so I can't tell you yet, but soon...
"Will you ever restart the Nerdfighter Blurbing
Book Club?"
Now, that's an idea. Hank, it's summertime,
and you know what that means in Nerdfighteria,
it means wearing SPF30 every time you go outside
and reading classic American literature for
fun!
Hank, I hereby announce that the new book
in the Nerdfighter Blurbing Book Club is none
other than The Great Gatsby by F. Scott Fitzgerald.
There's a link to purchase the book in the
doobly-doo, although, if you don't live in
the United States, it's probably public domain
and you can probably download it for free.
Regardless, it's cheap.
It's possible you've already read this book,
and maybe you even hated it, but that's because
you weren't reading it with me! So whether
you're reading it for the first time or reading
it again, that's our book! Let's read it!
The Great Gatsby!
"When are you gonna get Pizza John shirts
back in my size?"
Now! Bam! I just did it! Dftba.com/pizza!
I am here to solve your problems!
"How do I best confront the urge toward Nihilism?"
Well, not that kind of problem. Your smaller
problems. You know, pizza shirt related problems.
"What is the name of the hospital you were
born in?"
...asked the identity thief.
"Does the Yeti wear DFTBA shirts?"
Yes, but infuriatingly, she refuses to wear
a Pizza John shirt because she thinks it's
creepy. I don't know what's so creepy about
it.
"Never eat pizza again, or never--"
That one! The one where I can still eat pizza!
"What's Hank's punishment?"
Hank, I've chosen the punishment that was
most popular in Nerdfighteria, and that is
Humpy Hank All Over Town! I don't know why
Nerdfighters want to see that, but apparently
they do, so that's your punishment. Hump the
town.
"What are your thoughts on Tumblr?"
My thoughts? I think it's the number one destination
on the internet for images of Paula Dean riding
me.
"Do you think benign dictatorships are a good
form of government?"
To be honest, I think "benign dictatorship"
is a bit of an oxymoron.
"Who's your biggest inspiration?"
You. I know that's cheesy, but it's also the
truth. I write books and make videos because
I am inspired by you to try to tell you stories
that will be interesting and hopefully kind
of helpful?
I've seen my own life changed by books, and
honestly, there's just no greater inspiration
than the opportunity to do that for other
people.
"When teachers say 'the author means...' do
you really mean those things?"
Yeah, probably, but in my opinion, teachers
shouldn't say that because 1. teachers aren't
really in the business of reading authors'
minds, and 2. and more importantly, what authors
mean doesn't really matter, I don't think?
What's important is that critical reading
can be a way into thinking quite deeply about
questions that are difficult and complicated,
and not in some, like, boring and abstract
way, like, "Oh, in Moby Dick, white is a symbol
for nature's ambivalence to man," but instead
in a concrete and totally interesting way,
like, "Nature's complete indifference to you
as expressed by the color white in Moby Dick
is something that you had better get your
head around, or else you're going to end up
like Captain Ahab!"
So, it's so not much about uncovering secret
mysteries for the sake of uncovering secret
mysteries; it's about using story as a way
into thinking about our actual lives and how
we're actually living them. And that's how
we're going to try to read The Great Gatsby.
Hank, I'm gonna go pack; I will see you on
Friday!